you pick a movie lovers it's Jan here
although we've seen all the trailers
from Finiti war Marvel still haven't
revealed who Game of Thrones star Peter
Dinklage will be playing in the film so
today I'm going to give you a breakdown
of who his mystery character is most
likely to be and I'm kicking off a brand
new Avengers giveaway to enter you just
need to be a subscriber and leave me a
comment here about the movie also
remember to ring the bell to make sure
you get all my new videos
by the way MCU speculation and mild
spoilers ahead for Thor in infinity war
the character Peter Dinklage could well
be playing in the movie is eat tree king
of the dwarves of Nineveh Lear which is
one of the nine realms a tree who's a
master blacksmith was first introduced
in the Thor comics in the early 1980s
and later appeared on the animated TV
series The Avengers
Earth's Mightiest Heroes in the nfinity
war movie Thor travels to new devaglia
in search for new weapon and in the
comics there is a bond between new
devaglia and as god indeed it's the
dwarves who creates Thor's hammer
Mjolnir as well as an axe like hammer
called storm breaker which will be
Thor's new weapon in the movie in terms
of the MCU the dwarves of nit Evalia
have already made a brief appearance in
the prelude comic to Thor the dark world
where they feared an attack by trolls on
their forges because as god couldn't
protect them after the destruction of
the Bifrost
but the dwarves may well play a bigger
part in the infinity war movie as there
are rumors that they also created the
Infinity Gauntlet and that there have
been casting calls for actors of short
stature and there the possibility is
that Dinklage will play pip the troll a
prince who was transformed into a troll
and who loved to drink and have a good
time the character was created by artist
writer Jim Stalin who also gave us
Stannis Drax the destroyer and Gamora
pips appearances in the comics include
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline and he's
a member of the Infinity watch which was
put together by Adam warlock to protect
the infinity gems on top of that he's
also had his mind destroyed by Thanos
but Adam warlock came to the rescue
absorbing pips soul into the soul Jam
where he lived in Soul world until he
was restored into the real world via the
body of a recently deceased human now
Adam warlocks introduction to the MCU
he's dinner guardians of the galaxy to
post-credits scene however according to
James Gunn warlock won't appear till
guardians 3 but that doesn't necessarily
rule pip out of infinity war because in
addition to pips comic book connections
with Thanos Gamora and the infinity gems
early last year Peter Dinklage was
spotted getting his hair dyed red which
is just the right color to play pip the
troll there's also a chance that
Dinklage is lending his voice to one of
thanasis Black Order in an interview
with vulture Kevin Feige said there are
interesting people doing their voices so
far it looks like Terry notary and Tom
Vaughn Lawler will be playing two of the
Black Order possibly cull obsidian and
ebony more maybe Dinklage will voice
Corvus glaive who we already saw in the
trailers attacking vision for the mind
stone with his blade Dinklage would
certainly fall into the category of
interesting people that foggy mentions
however you think they might prefer to
give such a well-known actor a visual
broaden the vocal role then again we do
have Bradley Cooper as the voice of
rocket and James Spader was Ultron so
maybe they think a voice role would
potentially cause less confusion for
people who remember Dinklage's bolivar
trask
in x-men Days of Future past after all
Josh Brolin for example place Thanos in
the MCU through motion capture and voice
work but in Deadpool 2 he plays another
Marvel Comics character cable on screen
now I'd love to hear your thoughts and
theories on who Peter Dinklage will be
playing let me know in the comments and
make sure you're subscribed for the
giveaway tap here to check out my
spoiler free reaction to 20 minutes of
infinity war footage I saw and you can
watch my other Marvel series in my full
playlist here you can also tweet me any
questions or comments if you enjoyed
this I really appreciate you hitting
that like button and sharing the video
thanks for watching and see you next
time you PK movie lovers